[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport sur tv 60,18 l'émission à ne pas
manquer si vous êtes un amoureux du
sport local à ces parties a pour le
sommaire voile invité exceptionnel dans
quelques instants nous aurons avec nous
louis burton le skipper et vino a
terminé troisième du dernier vendée
globe il répondra à toutes nos questions
pour ce automobile coup de projecteur
sur jean pierre garcin le co pilote
originaire de montesson a participé
cette année à son 22e dakar il a terminé
une très belle 11e place son portrait et
a su dans ce magazine multisports nous
recevrons également dans cette émission
jean christophe maisonneuve un adepte du
coaching mental
il est notamment plusieurs sportifs
heavy loi dont l'équipe de volleyball de
conflans andrésy jouy l'actualité
sportive c'est maintenant sur tb 78
[Musique]
je vous le disais dans les titres invité
exceptionnel dans ce set 8 sports louis
burton le skipper évinois qui est arrivé
troisième du dernier vendée globe est
avec nous via écran interposé
bonsoir le bertone bonsoir en sont la
cause
alors avant de vous poser des questions
sur la course on va tout d'abord vous
poser cette question est ce que vous
avez pu récupérer est ce que vous êtes
quand même reposer
c'est quand même une bonne heure de
retrouver un lit confortable avec une
couette mais j'avoue être encore un peu
perturbée dans mon rythme de sommeil
donc voilà que la pression retombe donc
les douleurs apparaissent un petit peu
partout dans les jambes et tout mais bon
ça va
heureux d'être à terre que alors vous
êtes donc arrivé le 28 janvier dernier
dans la nuit vous êtes à ce moment là
deuxième qu'est ce qu'on ressent quand
on arrive à boucler ce tour du monde en
solitaire et sans escale mais on est
très très content et très fier
d'approcher la terre au bout de 80 jours
de course il ya malheureusement
énormément de difficultés et d'écueils
sur un tour du monde à la voile donc
beaucoup de personnes qui abandonnent
aussi et c'est vrai que quand on arrive
à passer entre les gouttes
on est très content on ou bien vous le
classement on a vraiment hâte de
retrouver les proches et ça soit terminé
voilà donc c'est et c'est un super
moment et puis quand on termine comme ça
dans les avant postes et bien évidemment
une fierté sportive importante vers qui
on se tourne tout de suite quand on
arrive à terre aux sables d'olonne 108
il est vrai que on attend sortir comme
ça de la nuit le premier semi rigide qui
vient nous chercher au large
c'est un grand moment d'émotion et puis
on essaye de devoir qui est à bord des
différents bateaux qui s'approche
quand les premiers proches c'est d'abord
l'équipe technique qui montent à bord du
bateau pour pour aider le solitaire qui
arrive fatigué qui a plus trop les
repères proche de la côte
et puis et puis très rapidement baron
on a hâte de retrouver sa douce et la
prendre dans les bras ses enfants son
frère sa famille proche ses amis quoi
c'est ça qui est très important
équipement pendant pendant ce grand
voyage au tour nouveau alors vous avez
finalement terminé à la 3ème position et
yannick bestaven nous passe devant pour
remporter ce vendée globe avec les
compensations suite au sauvetage de
kevin escoffier boris herrmann lui
percute un bateau de pêche quelques
heures avant l'arrivée ce qui vous
permet de finir du coup sur le podium
une réaction par rapport à ça c'est
encore un fait de course incroyable dans
ce vendée globe 2020
oui c'est sûr en fait les bonifications
ils ont été plus ou moins importante en
fonction du nombre d'heures qu'on
passait les quatre marins à se
rapprocher de kevin escoffier et boris
herrmann avait une bonification et voilà
et c'est vrai qu'en matière de voile et
en matière de sport il faut y croire
jusqu'au bout parce que ils allaient ils
allaient nous passer devant grâce à ces
bonifications et puis finalement à son
tour il rencontre un problème qui lui
fait perdre du temps cette collision est
donc finalement bassa bonification de
lui suffit plus à doubler les bateaux
qui sont devant lui donc voilà c'est le
malheur de langue qui fait le bonheur de
quelques quelques autres c'est vrai que
c'est un peu difficile
c'est un peu difficile pour lui parce
qu'il avait fait une belle morceau est
en effet gouttes ma deuxième place je
devais rire des 4e et lui fit alors
finalement dans ce vendée globe à tous
les skippers ont eu des démêlés aventure
on peut le dire au départ en novembre
dernier où vous avez connu à un faux
départ par exemple vous
comment se remet de ce faux départ est
ce que ça a vraiment pesé finalement sur
cette cette course c'est très difficile
de le gérer comme ça en faux départ
parce qu'en fait on coupe la ligne
quelques secondes trop tôt là où je suis
coincé à droite par par un autre bateau
qui m'empêche de glisse et sous le vent
et ralentir je suis pas prioritaire donc
j'ai pas le choix je suis obligé
d'avancer vers vers la ligne
et au moment où je me dis je vais partir
au vent et je vais je vais faire un tour
sur moi même mais je suis trop proche du
bateau militaire qui était au bout de
ligne pour être en sécurité
on n'a pas trop le choix on sait qu'on
connaît le tarif on sait qu'on va
prendre cinq heures pénalité donc c'est
très énervant la donne envie d'aller
encore plus vite
et voilà c'est ce que j'ai essayé à ce
moment une armée en effet alors l'un des
bons peut-être les plus difficiles de
votre course c'est cet arrêt sur l'île
macquarie au sud de l'australie
c'était en décembre dernier le 21
décembre vous deviez effectuer de
grosses réparations est ce que c'est le
moment le plus difficile peut-être de
votre course
oui c'est l'ensemble l'ensemble de cet
épisode a été a été la plus grosse
épreuve pour moi puisque en fait ça
commence ça commence par des problèmes
de pilote automatique
qui sont très compliquées quasiment
ingérable donc à ce moment là à ce
moment là avec le bateau durval est on
est on est à la deuxième position on n'a
pas envie de lâcher ça et on est
contraint et forcé de lâcher ça parce
que en solitaire mais on ne peut pas on
ne peut pas manoeuvrer continue la
course sans pilote
et puis en essayant de réparer ce pilote
le bateau va un peu où il veut il ya
plusieurs manoeuvres qui se passe de
manière involontaire est donc cette
casse en fait demain qui m'en empêche
ensuite l'utiliser ma grand voile dans
des conditions convenables et donc voilà
il faut ensuite trouver une solution
pour réparer donc il faut grimper tout
en haut du mât tout seul j'essaye de le
faire au large ça marche pas c'est trop
risqué trop dangereux je me fais mal
donc on cherche une option voilà d'aller
trouver un peu d'abri et donc on a été
sous cette terre du bout du monde on
peut pas s'arrêter donc c'était juste
pour casser les vagues et pouvoir monter
dans des conditions acceptables pour
aller faire ce gros ce gros travail dao
et puis une première fois j'y arrive pas
je monte une deuxième fois
et puis là je pense que c'est bon et je
repars essarts casse alors que sur
partie donc il faut à nouveau remettre
énormément d'énergie pour revenir vers
commencé encore une fois et donc ça a
été ça a été une série de des preuves
dans l'épreuve qu'ils ont été en effet
extrêmement difficile physiquement
moralement retrouver le courage de
remonter pour repartir et voilà au final
quand on connaît le résultat ensuite va
on se dit qu'on a bien fait et que ça
valait le coup on va justement regarder
une petite vidéo que vous aviez
enregistré justement sur cette île
macquarie et on revient juste à fait
si vous voyez bien le bateau ça ça fait
partie des trucs les plus les plus hard
que j'ai fait de ma vie de navigateurs
système 3 pour en tête de mât pour
remplacer look à j'espère que vous
apprécierez aussi du plus bas donc
maintenant on va descendre sans se
casser la figure
on va renvoyer l'arrivée et on va lui
même pour tous à une réaction par
rapport à cette vidéo louis burton
elle a fait le tour du monde dans cette
vidéo d'un c'est du full direct réel
sans filtre et c'est vrai que c'est vrai
que quand on est là oh et puis que c'est
bon on pense que c'est bon il ya une
explosion de joie d'émotion on est
terrorisée on voit sur la vidéo le
mousqueton qui me tient il n'arrive plus
à le fermer parce qu'il est tordue on
voit qui est qu'il est ouvert
la peur de tomber on sait qu'on est tout
seul que si ça se passe mal c'est
terminé donc pas que pour la course
donc c'est voilà c'est énormément
énormément de d'émotions de sensations
fortes et d'adrénaline
à haute dosé et voilà et c'est une joie
qui est aussi forte que la déception que
l'on a quand on pense que l'on va devoir
abandonner alors justement est ce que
vous avez pensé à l'abandon à ce moment
là j'ai entendu dire que votre team
vous avez soutenu vous avez encourager
et motiver pour pour continuer cette
aventure parce que c'était le cas enfin
oui c'est vrai que les problèmes de
pilote automatique ça vous savez que
l'issue elle est la même pour tout le
monde plus de pilote automatique plus de
courses et il faut abandonner donc on
essaye pendant des heures et des heures
et des heures ça veut pas ça ne
fonctionne pas donc pas un moment donné
on est quand même au milieu de rien on
n'a pas trop le choix donc il faut bien
tenir la barre et puis vous tenez la
barre jusqu'à quasiment l'épuisement
l'épuisement complet ça faisait déjà 24
heures ou un peu plus que j'avais fait à
dormir il a fallu barrer et 17h02 part
je n'en pouvais plus j'avais vraiment du
truc d'énergie et ça c'est le sait le
miracle de l'informatique et
d'électronique au goût de ses 17 heures
j'ai teint et je rallume le pilote et
puis ça se remet à marcher alors
pourquoi on ne sait toujours pas et ça
m'a permis de continuer oui euh tu vois
là et puis après avec cette grand voile
qui voulait plus monter c'est pareil que
je pensais vraiment aller en australie
parce que sans grand voile vous pouvez
pas faire la course non plus et puis
finalement on a trouvé cette solution et
et voilà et puis après il ya eu un sens
ni dans le pot-au-noir au retour la lie
avec l'énergie de vue tout dans le
bateau donc j'avais j'étais déjà en
train de choisir le port où j'allais
atterrir au brésil et puis et puis en
faisant les fils quand on dit
dans le jargon des voleurs de voiture il
va naviguer par des singes à remettre en
route un petit peu d'électricité pour
avoir le pilote et continuer le vendée
alors on va parler de l'avenir
maintenant louis burton
est-ce qu'il s'inscrit chez bureau
vallée je crois avoir luxe était prévu
que vous soyez chez bureau vallée
jusqu'en 2025 c'est le cas ouais c'est
beaucoup de beaucoup de chance et c'est
une période très compliquée et dans
laquelle il faut il faut mesurer faut
mesurer encore plus que d'habitude lâche
la chance que l'on a d'être accompagné
dans dans notre sport dans notre passion
un par un par un partenaire et sponsor
moi ça fait ça fait dix ans on entre
dans la onzième année de notre
collaboration et et qui renouvelle qu'il
me renouvellent leur confiance de cette
manière là ça me ça me touche au plus
profond de moi et c'est vrai qu'avant le
départ de la course
on s'était dit qu'on continuerait au
moins une année après le vendée globe
mais mais là ce ce contrat-là ce deal de
repartir encore pendant cinq ans c'est
formidable et et évidemment c'est très
motivant pour toute l'équipe pour moi
même et puis en plus qu'on va pouvoir le
faire probablement ce soit avec un
bureau vallée de améliorer soit avec un
nouveau bateau
c'est des choses qu'on avancera demain
et voilà c'est c'est une chance énorme
encore plus oui un nouveau bateau plus
performant c'est ça c'est ce que vous
recherchez
forcément oui alors la magie de la
technique c'est qu'il ya plusieurs
options et toi construire vos bateaux
soissons acheté un euro revendu plus ici
ou alors même modifier celui ci il ya
plein de possibilités et on a travaillé
activement depuis que chauffer entre et
surtout toute possibilité là et voilà on
aura des jolies choses à dire demain
dernière question tout simplement une
victoire ce sera l'objectif sur le
prochain vendée globe ou en tout cas une
deuxième place mieux que j'ai vu que
cette année bah c'est vrai qu'en quand
on coupe la quand on coupe la ligne
d'arrivée d'une course comme le vendée à
la deuxième position le mieux qu'on
puisse viser après c'est la première
donc ce sera clairement l'objectif de ce
sera clairement l'objectif du vendée
globe dans quatre ans pour moi et entre
temps entre temps on va essayer de faire
mieux sur les transats jacques vabre et
sur la route du rhum donc ma meilleure
place est cinquième sur ces courses là
donc on va viser mieux en valise et un
podium sur ses comptes
merci à vous louis burton on vous
souhaite le meilleur et surtout de
bonnes vacances je crois que vous allez
bientôt partir en vacances ou souhaite
de bien vous reposer on continuera
évidemment vous suivre sur atv à 78
merci louis burton
alors on va maintenant on va maintenant
ouvrir une page sport automobile 1 y
vino a terminé le rallye dakar à cette
année selon jean pierre garcin le co
pilote originaire de montesson au 22
participations sur cette épreuve s'est
classé à une belle 11e place son
portrait des images de grégory à canal
et avantages de matteo luxereau et
marina lh2 là à barbe et il a brillé sur
les dunes d'arabie saoudite en janvier
dernier jean pierre garcin est l'un des
meilleurs copilotes sur le rallye dakar
cet habitant de montesson est arrivé
onzième position avec son coéquipier
christian lavieille mon objectif c'était
de faire 10 dont dakar
on a fini 11e voilà on est pendant
longtemps été 10e et puis on s'est fait
rattraper par un pilote très connue
c'est cyril després un ancien vainqueur
moto et c'était pas grave parce que les
moyens n'étaient pas engagés n'était pas
du tout les mêmes voilà donc on était
plutôt satisfait de la course comme jean
pierre garcin et les courses automobiles
cette histoire commence dès l'enfance
passionné de voitures et de motos que
sportif grandi avec un père garagiste un
oncle pilotes
il commence à faire des compétitions en
amateur à 25 ans avant de se spécialiser
dans les quatre 4 commenter ce n'est
dispute son premier dakar en 1996 en
tant que copilote
un rôle qu'il ne quittera plus pour être
pilote foire du talent voilà et moi je
me suis amusé pendant longtemps à faire
des courses de voitures en amateur mais
j'avais surtout pas le talent
on peut tous les tous les pilotes
peuvent faire le dakar c'est qu'une
question d'argent mais après pour un
roulé un rythme élevé et où faut avoir
du talent voilà et donc là je n'ai pas
donc ça ne m'a jamais effleuré l'esprit
aujourd'hui à 58 ans jean pierre garcin
disputé 22 dakar dans sa carrière une
expérience précieuse dans la navigation
mon rôle c'est lui donner le maximum
d'informations le plus précis possible
dans la voiture à un moment donné elle
l'expérience j'ai eu beaucoup quoi parce
que le désert partout dans le monde il
est le même en chine en arabie saoudite
en afrique en australie le désert ça
revient toujours la même chose et la
connaissance du terrain elle est très
importante quoi savoir ce qu'on me le
visuel ça parce qu'on va rencontrer
c'est ce primordial cette histoire
d'amour entre jean pierre garcin et le
dakar n'est pas prêt de se terminer
libinois pense déjà à repartir l'année
prochaine
bonjour ou temps n'a plus envie qui va
plus voilà ça c'est clair franchement
c'est de cette année ç'a tellement été
agréable que je me vois pas ne pas y
aller on pense déjà comme on va y aller
ça c'est vrai il espère cette fois-ci
finir dans le top 10 un dernier objectif
avant de terminer sa carrière à 60 ans
du cyclisme à présent la piste du
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines accueilli ce
week-end les championnats de france
handisport 2021 l'un des derniers rendez
vous avant les jeux paralympiques de
tokyo une dizaine d'athlètes de haut
niveau à participer à ce rendez vous
parmi eux le binôme françois pervis
raphaël bogies et le duo a raflé le
triplé de vitesse en poursuite et au
kilomètre tout cela sans réelle
préparation
de bonne augure pour les jo de tokyo
fois toujours un cyclisme à une centaine
de mètres du vélotour national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'île de
loisirs va accueillir les championnats
de france de cyclo cross ce dimanche 21
février au programme des courses cadets
cadettes juniors hommes et femmes ainsi
que des courses master's laurent des
voix a reçu le feu vert des autorités le
rendez-vous sera organisé à huis clos à
cause du contexte sanitaire
on va maintenant parler de coaching
mental pour parler de cette thématique
nous avons avec nous en plateau
jean-christophe maisonneuve vous êtes
préparateur mental de l'équipe 1
masculine de volleyball de conflans
andresy jouy ou s'occupent également de
plusieurs athlètes yvelinois alors tout
d'abord en quoi consiste votre métier
alors déjà j'aime à dire préparateur
mental et pas coaching mental on est
comme un préparateur physique mais pour
le mental la préparation mentale
elle est au service de la performance
d'un individu ou d'un collectif en
travaillant de manière spécifique sur
des habiletés mentales
ce qu'on appelle les habiletés mentales
ça va être tout ce qui va être gestion
des émotions du stress la confiance en
soi et autres alors vous travaillez avec
des clubs comme conflent par exemple en
volleyball en quoi consiste votre votre
métier avec eux qu'est ce que comment
vous les suivez au quotidien en une dans
une saison alors en fait il ya deux
approches canton quand on travaille avec
un club et un collectif on va avoir une
approche individuelle et une approche
collective
donc il faut que je puisse connaître
chacun des individus pour connaître
leurs vins de l'été mentale dont je
parle et leur type de réaction en
fonction de quelle situation
comment ils réagissent en fonction de
quelle situation de stress quelle
situation de match et vis-à-vis
d'eux-mêmes et vis-à-vis du collectif et
ensuite je suis aussi présent aux
entraînements et surtout au match pour
pouvoir distinguer voir les situations
collectives des réactions individuelles
par exemple vous vous analysez des faits
de jeu par exemple la réaction du joueur
c'est bien ça oui c'est à dire que moi
mon approche pas du tout technique je me
détache complètement il ya un staff qui
est vraiment performant pour ça je suis
plus sur l'observation qui va être sûr
du comportement un comportement il faut
pas oublier qu'aujourd'hui un
comportement de performance c'est lié à
une pensée qui va générer une émotion
qui va générer un comportement et c'est
le cercle qui peut être vertueux qui
malheureusement peut être vicieux du
coup plutôt sur des phases négative
peut-être ou pas l'un ou l'autre c'est à
dire que je vais capitaliser sur les
réactions positives et évidemment quand
il y à des événements plutôt négatif on
essaie d'analyser après avec le sportif
quels sont les types d'émotions qui sont
passés par là et de comprendre pourquoi
est ce que c'est une frustration par
rapport à un objectif qui s'était fixé
dans sa tête
est ce que c'est une frustration même
par rapport au regard de ses coéquipiers
voire de son entraîneur
et où une frustration tout simplement
parce qu'ils n'arrivent pas à mettre en
place en match ce qu'il a travaillé à
l'entraînement alors vous êtes un ancien
sportif vous avez pratiqué du sport est
ce que ça vous êtes justement à
peut-être plus crédit peut être aux yeux
des percées que vous préparez plus
crédible je sais pas en tout cas moi j'y
trouve la source de hors jeu pas dire
mon inspiration de ce que j'ai quand
même bénéficié de différentes formations
pour être préparateur mental mais
effectivement j'ai joué au rugby en
première division
j'ai joué au volley au niveau national
aussi
et les phases de jeu qui à l'époque
n'était pas du tout reliée à on associer
pas du tout ce qu'on vivait à de la
préparation mentale on le vivais et puis
il fallait le vivre et il fallait avoir
un mental d'acier on va dire sinon on
était ce qu'on considérait comme une
chochotte ce que pour certains
malheureusement considère encore la
préparation mentale pour les gens qui
ont des problèmes psy ou qui sont pas
bien dans leur tête
est ce que le coaching mental aides à la
performance réellement c'est censé être
l'objectif premier
on est en fait on va travailler la
performance pour moi c'est le potentiel
de chaque individu
- les interférences et interférences
j'en parlais ça peut être un discours ce
qu'on peut appeler un discours interne
la façon dont on va se parler qui est
plus ou moins positive des joueurs de
tennis par exemple quand il n'arrive pas
à mettre en place les choses ils se
parlent de manière très négative ils
s'insultent même à l'intérieur
voir à l'extérieur ils peuvent casser
une raquette et 7 ce comportement influe
sur la performance c'est à dire qu'on va
perdre sa concentration on va perdre sa
motivation le plaisir à jouer et plein
de choses vont découler de cette
attitude alors que si on adopte une
attitude positive qui permet de rester
concentré qui permet d'être focus dans
son match on va pouvoir adopter un
comportement qui va amener à la
performance il faut s'entraîner comme
une fois par semaine à peu près
la préparation mentale c'est un travail
quotidien
c'est pour elle comparé à la préparation
physique
quelqu'un qui a besoin je prends un
volleyeur qui a besoin de travailler sa
détente
il va travailler différents groupes
musculaires de différentes façons et le
résultat va pas venir deux jours après
ni un mois après s'ils s'entraînent
qu'une fois c'est exactement la même
chose pour la préparation mentale c'est
un travail c'est ce qu'on appelle des
connexions neuronales des autoroutes
neuronaux pour relier des connexions
entre le cerveau et le corps que l'on
n'a pas forcément l'habitude de
travailler et que plus on travaille plus
on prend l'habitude de le travailler et
plus ce sera facile à mettre en place et
à mettre en oeuvre
on est deux skippers et vinuales ou
burton qui était à cette émission ou
pour ce qu'il est parfaitement préparé
lui avant avant une échéance comme celle
là alors je pense que vous vouliez
réagir de ses genoux sont bien préparés
et bien sûr certains d'ailleurs vérifie
si d'un préparateur mental sont de plus
en plus nombreux il faut savoir qu'un
skipper qui part faire le vendée globe
il l'a dit un il se retrouve seul le
moindre accident ne pardonne pas surtout
quand il était en haut de son mât ville
ils sont sujets à des normes émotions
ses émotions elles peuvent être très
positive mais elles peuvent les faire
sombrer donc il faut avoir un mental
solide
il faut être avoir une capacité de
concentration très spécifique au vendée
globe
enfin ou en tout cas à ce métier de
skipper c'est à dire que la moindre
faute ne pardonne pas l'océan est de
toute façon plus fort que vous donc
comment faire pour travailler tout ça
comment se placer par rapport à tout cet
environnement
ça se prépare de la même façon un
triathlète ou un marathonien va lui se
battre contre lui et contre son envie
d'abandonner ou pas contre les douleurs
qui la lui et ça il faut qu'il le
travail certains certaines personnes
vont devoir comme les skieurs
retravailler tout leur circuit une
visuellement et mentalement parce que
c'est pareil la moindre erreur peut être
fatale
donc voilà tous les sports on
loin d'un niveau de concentration d'un
niveau de gestion des motions pour pas
partir non plus dans tous les sens si
jamais le besoin se fait sentir
dernière question combien ça coûte tout
simplement de se faire suivre d'être
préparé physiquement et mentalement
alors je vais pas pouvoir répondre parce
qu'il ya des tarifs très différents dans
le métier je vais plutôt répondre en
disant si vous voulez vous investir dans
une préparation mentale suivra
préparateur mental
l'investissement que vous y mettez doit
être à la hauteur de l'investissement
mental que vous allez y mettre alors je
veux pas dire que financièrement il n'y
a pas de lui c'est pas vrai tout dépend
d'eux des circuits je ne connais pas
tous les hauts niveaux du corps sur
votre site internet
exactement qui s'affiche justement à
l'écran très bien voilà merci beaucoup
pour votre venue sur le plateau à
répondre à nos interrogations sur cette
thématique intéressante qui est le
coaching mental hameau de rugby à
présent la fédération française prendra
une décision le 26 février prochain sur
la suite des compétitions de rugby
amateur la ffr précise qu'il s'agit de
la date limite pour pouvoir tenir un
calendrier des compétitions cohérent et
respectueux de l'équité sportive
mais si la situation sanitaire n'évolue
pas des décisions seront prises
certaines rumeurs pessimistes parlent
d'une saison blanche et d'une reprise à
la rentrée prochaine
toutes les réponses à ces rumeurs sont
apportées à la fin du mois les i mean
conclu le 30 me licencier dans ces clubs
de rugby tient on prend maintenant à la
direction de poissy ce jeudi le
capitaine du paris saint-germain
marquinhos et le milieu de terrain ander
herrera ont rendu visite à des enfants
hospitalisés
le rendez-vous a été organisé par la
fondation psg ils ont attribué à cette
distribués à cette occasion des cadeaux
de noël aux jeunes et ils ont évidemment
signé quelques autographes lors de cet
après midi en termine a part ca images
du camp des loges à
saint-germain-en-laye ce dimanche à deux
jours du choc en ligue des champions
contre le barça plus de 300 supporters
dont un des membres du collectif ultra
paris se sont réunis avec des banderoles
des drapeaux des fumigènes pour
encourager les joueurs parisiens et ils
ont fait à beaucoup de
le match aller se jouera ce mardi soir à
huis clos au camp nou en catalogne
c'est la fin de cette émission à merci
d'avoir suivi à très belle soirée sur tv
[Musique]